-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well,
and let's get to the news.
President Biden received his
coronavirus vaccine booster shot
yesterday, or as Fox News
reported, heroin.
While receiving his coronavirus
vaccine booster shot yesterday,
President Biden told reporters
"I know it doesn't look like it,
but I am over 65."
But I don't know what's worse,
how corny that joke is
or the fact that he's been using
it for 13 years.
Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell yesterday
also received a coronavirus
vaccine booster shot.
McConnell received
a shot in his hand because,
of course,
he tried to block it.
[ Vocalizes ]
Defense Secretary Lloyd Austin
and joint chiefs of staff
Chairman General Mark Milley
appeared publicly today
before the Senate for the first
time since the U.S.
withdrawal from Afghanistan,
and they immediately
had to be evacuated,
"Go, go, go!
We didn't think
it'd be this bad!"
According to a new book by
ex-White House press secretary
Stephanie Grisham,
former President Trump
cuts his own hair with a huge
pair of scissors that would
"cut a ribbon at an opening of
one of his properties."
And now, two years later,
the bank owns his hair.
After the adult film star
Stormy Daniels described
former President Trump's penis
in an interview,
Trump purportedly called then
White House staffer
Stephanie Grisham and assured he
that Daniels' description
was incorrect, I can't imagine
exactly what he said
but probably something like...
-I was in the pool!
I was in the pool!
-Something like that.
President Biden is reportedly
annoyed at the White House
press corps for asking off-topic
questions.
As a string of recent meetings
with foreign leaders,
besides, he has no idea why
Samantha's not coming back.
The annual
Congressional Baseball Game
is set for tomorrow, pitting
Democrats against Republicans,
so hurry up and pick a team,
Joe.
French President Emmanuel Macron
was hit by an egg yesterday
while touring an international
food trade fair.
Said Macron, "That's ah-neuf."
[ Laughter ]
Karen Chee submitted that joke
and in her submission said to
Alex Baze, "I believe that this
joke is perfect."
[ Laughter ]
Is that accurate, Baze?
So, do please, go to...
where you'll be
given the option of voting
"Yes, that was a perfect joke."
Or "Karen."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, C-Span recently
unveiled a new app called
C-Span now, also available on
most White Noise apps.
And that was the Monologue.